let's talk about what they said about
steve bannon because this one i think is
really interesting we got this from the
independent steve bannon pledges 20 000
shock troops ready to go as he rants
that we control this country donald
trump's former strategist has called on
gop to deconstruct the state
the independent reports mr bannon made
the comments as he said he had rallied
republican supporters to deconstruct the
state when the party wins the white
house again
if you're going to take over the
administrative state and deconstruct it
then you have to have shock troops
prepare to take it over immediately mr
bannon spoke to the newly formed
association of republican presidential
appointees which was formed to help
future gop officials fill thousands of
federal jobs if they win the oval office
again he told the new network that he
wanted to see pre-trained teams ready to
jump into federal agencies at the start
of the next gop presidency and he
doubled down on the claim on his monday
broadcast unreal america's voice now
here's funny
what is steve bannon saying
if a republican wins the white house
again he thinks there should be people
ready to just immediately take up
appointments
once they're in start dismantling the
bureaucratic state
he had stated that one of the troubles
that trump had was he wasn't able to
appoint enough people quickly enough to
gain control and thus he was jammed up
the whole time
how do they frame it
shock troops
well he said that but they're making it
seem like he's talking about like street
violence now more importantly when you
look at how social media deals with this
what are the what is the left saying it
look what is the left saying they look
at these stories they don't read them so
what do they think
all of the comments are basically like
he's he's pledging insurrection and
domestic terror why won't they go after
him they're claiming that steve bannon
admitted
that he organized the insurrection when
he said that he was involved with he had
like consulted on the planning of a
rally you know on january 6 or whatever
which is not
any right at the capitol
but these people don't read the actual
news story so it's funny because it
sounds like when steve bannon says we
control this country he's talking about
the people when he was on this show he
said text the rich you're getting ripped
off and i'm like steve that's like a
kind of leftist position right-wing
people don't say text the rich and they
argue with me when i do and he's like
well i'm a populist so when he says we
control this country he's talking about
the people but the media is effective at
taking your words out of context and
making it seem like you're far right or
fringe or whatever and here you go
with that being said if parents revolt
and we end up seeing some kind of red
wave
will bannon's
supposed
administrative shock troops dismantle
this country
well it depends what you talk about when
we say dismantling i think the the right
has very little power very little
institution power very little cultural
power so the chances of that i mean i
don't know a lot of people are just not
happy with the republicans to be honest
with you i mean they see them as lame
ducks they see them as pathetic people
who just sit back twiddle their thumbs
and say one thing vote another way and
then sell out their constituents as of
course they take their money and promise
everything and deliver nothing so
there's a lot of discontent so will they
dismantle anything well the likelihood
of them doing that let's be honest here
is very impossible since they don't have
any institutional power to do so i kind
of feel like it's a pipe dream on the
part of people who are upset with the
bureaucratic state so some people call
it the deep state and i think it's
referred to as like what is it called
permanent government
administrative state yeah yeah so this
is i mean this is important stuff to
consider when a president gets elected
these heads of intelligence agencies
stay there
with more access to knowledge and that
is just a critical uh um point of
failure for for our country
if we're supposed to have elected
representatives who come in to enact
their agenda
but you have people who are unable to
gain more power more control over a
longer period of time through
appointment
then we're not a constitutional republic
with democratically elected
representatives are we am i the only
person here that doesn't feel a lot of
hope in the whole phrase and concept of
we the people anymore
i mean and i mean that because i
genuinely feel like the administrative
state if you want to call them that is
just too strong yes we have parents
pushing back locally
they're going to be labeled terrorists
i have another point about that later
but
at this point what do you really do i
don't know i don't know if
because even these people these parents
you know they're
getting engaged on a local level they uh
they still have to communicate via
social media at some point so what if
they just unplug it you know aren't they
gonna pull every single trick that they
can possibly manage in order to uh make
sure that the people don't have any kind
of power against such a big ugly machine
i i think hope in congress is absolutely
delusional but i do think there are some
significant
things that have developed within the
last few months especially on the local
level that do deserve to be talked about
places like florida places like texas
places like new hampshire have initially
been
living under a totally different system
than a lot of other people in the rest
of the united states they have been
making their own calls their own
decisions a lot of them you could debate
whether they were right or wrong but
also when we look at gun rights they
have been actually expanding in some
states that have been passing laws
constitutional carry laws and provisions
where the federal government is against
it but locally on a state level things
like that have been passing and
some people are even arguing we're
getting more gun rights than we ever had
that's true in in recent uh history so
look at look at the map look at the
there's a map of constitutional carry
from the 80s it didn't exist exactly
true that's crazy
you compare it now and it's it's it's
amazing it's it's great to see and of
course the the crime statistics kind of
speak for themselves when you have
constitutional carry and when you have
gun ownership comparatively to when you
ban gun ownership but there's a lot of
different factors to facilitate there as
well but but on that kind of level i do
think there is room for optimism and
hope because we have seen incredible
things that have gotten rid of a lot of
bureaucracy gotten rid of a lot of big
government federal level i think it's
becoming more and more irrelevant
because a lot of states are just saying
no i'm not going to listen to you uh we
saw ron desantis we've seen other states
say atf uh you're not you're not coming
in here uh fbi you're not coming in here
to to harass our parents this is not
going to happen here california and
immigration yeah um you know there's so
many other examples of this and i think
we're moving towards another form of
government where the federal government
is becoming less and less relevant which
is amazing good to see and exciting for
me personally so is that why the federal
government's essentially panicking yeah
i think so because people aren't
listening to them they can't really do
much um what are they going to do in
florida we saw joe biden attack florida
viciously we saw dr fauci say there's
going to be a bloodbath in florida we
saw the mainstream media say that
there's going to be bodies piled on
miami beach there's going to be you know
a reckoning happening because they're
not listening to our overlord mr fauci
and mr yeah whatever whoever whatever it
is that was the insult of insults yeah
really
no again
they just said screw you guys we're not
doing it and what happened their numbers
are comparatively to california where
they had the strictest lockdowns you
know highlighting how oh but we've seen
this over and over again you know so and
it's hard to understand why the waves
come and go i'm not going to pretend to
be you know like you look at some places
like sweden and they have no big spikes
and there's a big spike some at some
point i don't know i don't have all the
answers on that i can say
i don't think there's ever a reason to
believe that a small handful of elitist
authoritarians are gonna be able to lead
the country more effectively than a
decentralized will of the people
i don't think will the people is perfect
i certainly think that
you know direct democracy doesn't work
so there has to be some safeguards like
a constitutional republic but the people
electing representatives at least is
some safeguard to
mob rule not perfect a little bit better
but what's the alternative now joe biden
ruling by decree joe biden comes out and
says that if you don't support his
agenda you're supporting the decline of
this country you're either with me or
against me it was bad when bush made the
same illusions it's bad when biden does
it now he said complicit
is that he said yeah complicit that's
but that that's one of those words
that's been hijacked by the social
justice warriors right it's like you're
complicit in white supremacy if you
don't confess there was that recent ted
talk by er ever max kendy where he talks
about confession i mean he literally
uses this religious language and i mean
we've all seen that for a while but he's
literally using it now and there's that
complicit if you're complicit with your
white supremacy if you're complicit with
allowing this country to deteriorate
it's your fault you're the racist and
you're part of the problem he's he's
he's basically complimenting the end
caps and the libertarians and to a
certain extent you know it's funny
because antifa claims to be
anti-authoritarian but all of the
antiviral people on on my facebook are
absolutely pro-government right now and
it's just like y'all are dumb
yeah look at what they're protesting
they're protesting against people who
are going against mass mandates who are
protesting against the state yeah
they're protesting literally for state
initiative efforts that that go after
and punish people for not complying with
big bureaucratic government i will say
though it's getting to that point where
i was surprised that these antifa people
were like you know i'm talking to people
on facebook who are like you know
leftist or whatever that i've known
since like occupied and they're saying
things like there's no vaccine mandate
and i'm like well first let's let me ask
you this is
vaccine mandate would you consider that
statist authoritarianism well of course
but it's not happening and i'm like i
guess you don't read the news here's
article article articles all these
articles and they're like well that's
that's not the state and then i'm like
here is an article saying quite
literally the state is mandating we wow
these people don't read the news yeah
and they only know what's funneled to
them through their activist friends i
suppose well through their social media
carefully curated echo chamber that
they're that they're in and and we have
to understand they see news they see
videos they see photos that are
completely different than what we see
than what the average person sees
because they're getting literally just
their constant uh reinformant of this
craziness and this nonsense and they
don't see that there's another world
that there's another reality out there
and this is happening more and more
people are being politicized more and
more to extreme lengths where again
peaceful divorce is a real conversation
and i think it is possibly attainable i
don't think it's possibly attainable i
think it's happening yeah i don't think
i i don't think it's an issue of
you know what what i don't need to
advocate for
when you've got the state of jefferson
people you've got infighting in these
different counties when you've got
california you know with the northern
part wanting to leave partly you know in
relation to the state of jefferson but
also just wanting to be separate when
you've got states like texas and new
hampshire
you know it is it is we're at the point
now where we've talked about it so much
it's just being a dead horse but i mean
these states are saying no to the
federal government yeah i mean they're
even doing their own thing there's even
blm protesters marching with trump
protesters against the vax mandates in
new york city huge whitefield yeah that
was a great site so so seeing something
like that shows you that you know not
all hope is lost the only reason that
these bureaucrats have control over
people is over this illusion that they
have to be participating in this corrupt
system and they don't all that needs to
happen is people walk away and start
living their own lives peacefully
without trying to hurt anyone and it's
as simple as that thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you